ask embrace my name is Pete
today we're gonna play with a new
website from Microsoft which is called
how old net I'm sure you've seen it
somewhere and basically it's this thing
where you can upload a photo let's use
this example photo and it will tell you
how old all these people are how does it
work
let's find out let's start with myself
okay let's try this picture I'm 27
so I guess I don't look my age huh I'm
25 by the way thank you very much
Microsoft let's see how consistent it is
25 okay that's pretty impressive that
they guessed that but technically that
picture was taken a year ago so should
have been 24 28 damn Hey
what about dr. Phil 36 damn dr. Phil you
lost a few years 39 okay I always wonder
how old a little [ __ ] from the grudge's
is six damn how do they know how do they
know that
let's try me and mindset I'm 30 34 [ __ ]
please my cell looks like she's 12
come on how can it be so consistently
unconcerned I don't understand 443 why
454 why 83 he's young 33 still in my
limit I can go there I always wonder how
old Gordon Freeman was 27 Jesus Christ
he's a total badass for his age let's
try cloud from final fantasy
fifteen so [ __ ] sure about lightning
23 okay how old is link 29 okay that
makes sense
23 it really jumps in ages a lot doesn't
he Jesus Christ let's check how old
Zelda's 10 you've done it link you
[ __ ] done it 10 again oh man
link you [ __ ] perv man what the [ __ ]
my link what are you doing link alright
friends you can check out this website
yourself a link it in a description
there's a lot of fun to mess around with
I hope you enjoyed this video if you did
hit a like click here for more similar
videos and as always I'll see in the
next one
stay awesome giving you don't deny my
yoga belt [ __ ] what